there is
a very real
seattle seahawks and quarterback russell
wilson now i don't know how much of it
is coming from the seahawks
but it's clearly
something
that's coming from
russell wilson who
as the pot is boiling
was on dan patrick's show yesterday
not mincing words
not tiptoeing around
the issues not sending passive
aggressive message messages that then
would be denied if those of us in the
media happen to notice those messages
and talk about them like your favorite
quarterback tends to that's wrong
russell
it's not wrong it's entirely it's not a
cheap shop
nothing's for sure for the next year
that's all he pointed out you you decide
to take everything from there that was
you not right aaron rod has a proven
history of making passive aggressive
comments aimed at sending messages to
the organization and then when those of
us try to flesh out what he's saying he
gets pissed off where how dare you stop
this time where did he go i still
haven't heard a contract thing any of
that so sorry i'll go no yeah no he just
drops this turd in the punch bowl right
after the nfc championship game a lot of
futures here undecided myself included
and then acts like he didn't say
anything and even then even then with
the stuff he said on pat mcafee show if
you parse through it and i didn't do it
because frankly i can only handle so
much of geonon okay but some of the
packers beat writers tried to parse
through the things he said to say well
he's still suggesting there's something
going on here and we'll get we'll get to
your we'll get to your your friend your
unrequited friend later for now this is
about russell wilson who we didn't have
on the show last week and i thought
maybe he's keeping a low profile because
most super bowl weeks we have him and
last year we got him to say some
revealing stuff about his i don't want
to say dissatisfaction with the offense
but the areas in which he would like to
see a change that became
in some respects the the guts of let
russ cook
well they let him cook in the meal kind
of eventually blew up on everyone in
part because the offense didn't change
anyway this is an outgrowth of what
we've been talking about yeah the tom
brady effect
20 years of
do your bleeping job has become hey
quarterback your job is to bring in
anyone that you think is going to help
us win and we're not going to tell you
no now there's a middle ground there
somewhere and i think russell wilson
would like to find some of it and let's
start with that appearing yesterday with
dan patrick russell wilson
on his desire
to maybe have some say
in who he's playing with on both sides
of the ball he is
how much input should the quarterback
have in
organizational moves veteran quarterback
yeah i think it depends on who it is you
know i think how about you how much do
you have any say in what seattle does
offensively with free agents or draft
draft picks
uh
uh i think that it's uh
you know i think that ultimately for me
personally i you know i think that i
want to be able to have be involved
because at the end of the day it's your
legacy it's your team's legacy it's you
know it's the guys you get to go into
the huddle with that's a long-winded way
of not answering my question are you
involved in personnel decisions have you
been involved in personnel decisions
not not as much i don't you know i think
that uh you know do you want to be
involved russ yeah i think it helps i
think it helps to be involved more um
but i think that's that dialogue should
happen more often
damn would have been a hell of a lawyer
speaking of guys who aren't seriously
because he got to the truth
and can we handle the truth can the
seahawks handle the truth i'm not sure
they can i'm not sure seahawks fans can
because this thing's been lingering for
a few years just the idea that maybe at
some point russell wilson is not going
to be on the seahawks and the 12s get
very upset they they immediately go to
20 when you start talking about the
possibility of a future without russell
wilson but
hey
he
look he's articulating something i've
believed for a while now if you
are going to expect the quarterback
to be
the boss on the shop floor
the quasi member of management the one
who inspires leads holds accountable
works hard shows up early stays late
sets the example
you can't freeze him out
of the management meetings you can't say
when it's time to convene in the boss's
office sorry russ you're just one of the
employees get back to work keep doing
the things we want you to do among the
other workers keep sending our message
remember there was a resentment of
russell wilson early in his career
because he was considered too much of a
company man he's been a company man
through and through and what's the
company done for him and i think he's at
the point where he wants to have some
say
clearly clearly he wants to have some
say in who they bring on board yeah i
mean clearly i i get it to a degree
i think you're
you know
towing a very dangerous line when you
start to get into these conversations
why well why because one you're the
quarterback and you are the player the
general is the head coach there's other
guys that are you know there to evaluate
players and put the team together and i
think that's why tom brady get to do it
because he's won six super bowls before
he did it and he brought a guy one that
is a first ballot hall of famer who was
just out of the league for one so that
was an enio brown we know there's a
history there and then we got leonard
fournette who came because he was there
it doesn't he didn't call him up but
this is a rare instance we're talking
about the goat we're talking about tom
brady the greatest leader in the history
of the nfl who's earned you know
multiple pelts on the wall the horses
whatever medals trophies rings whatever
and he's now just getting the
opportunity to do that in a very rare
situation with a cool gm and a cool head
coach where they just asked them about
two or three guys that's that's to me
where
you know like hey it's one thing to go
hey russell we're thinking about this
receiver or this receiver you know do
you got a feel here and you know who do
you like and what do you like about this
guy that's one thing but if you're gonna
start going hey russell like what do you
think about free agency what do you want
us to do in the draft you know then i
would go well then russell stop doing
dan patrick interviews and start getting
in there and watching film on free
agents and drop pics because you can't
tell okay start telling them that he
would do but he would okay well well i i
don't think he wants to be assistant
general manager i just think he he wants
to have some say some influence some
input
in in who they're going to acquire and
who they're going to pursue and remember
what's coming what's coming is chaos if
the salary cap drops 180 million guys
are going to be cut free agents aren't
going to get that big money right out of
the gates they're going to be wondering
where is where where's my payday well
screw it it's coming next year i'll go
sign with a team that i think will help
me win a championship hey russell wilson
hey aaron rodgers hey tom brady hey
patrick mahomes those are the four guys
we spent a lot of time on monday among
the pft writers trying to drill down to
who are the guys who are in a position
to try to recruit
for lack of a better phrase a super team
right
right and i think it's guys who are
shortlist franchise quarterbacks who
have already shown they can get to the
top of the mountain yeah those four guys
agreed right and maybe deshawn watson
maybe wherever desean watson goes if he
goes anywhere maybe him yeah i think
josh allen's probably in that convoy too
i'm just gonna say that just a guy where
you go i'd go with him you know
at least that yeah right now josh
allen's still wet behind the right ears
right right or what behind the ears
depending upon your preference
but but with russell wilson he's got
nine years in he's keenly aware of his
football mortality he's getting toward
the midpoint of his intended
shelf life of age 45. he's been talking
about playing until he's 45 for
four or five years frankly so
the question becomes and i think it's
gotta be tormenting to him he mentioned
this yesterday to dan patrick he hates
watching other guys playing for a super
bowl here he is
six years after
squaring off against tom brady brady's
still doing it
and russell hasn't been past
the divisional round
since 2014. think about that brady's
been to the conference championship or
beyond every year since
then except 2019 his final year at the
patriots russell hasn't gotten past the
divisional round once well there's gonna
be a lot of quarterbacks that could say
that though mike i mean i know you know
new england not everybody had the
benefit of having new england and having
that brady was a part of something
special and of course he's special too
i'm not trying to say that
and you know
it's hard to replicate that and you're
right i do feel like these quarterbacks
are kind of feeling the pressure now and
especially because he left you know new
england and went somewhere and got
another super bowl they're feeling the
pressure i feel like a lot like the nba
players a little bit they're going wait
why should i sit with one team and have
them determine my legacy and one other
guy gets to drafted by one team and you
know they really help his legacy so i
think these guys are looking at and
going wait why don't i make my own moves
and i'll make my own legacy and figure
this out myself because i want to be
talked in that way 30 years from now or
whatever and i do think you know between
antonio brown the nba players and like
you're saying tom tom brady that has
definitely opened some quarterbacks eyes
for sure
this gets back to our conversation from
a few months ago when i was trying to
articulate
why it irritates me that jamal adams the
seahawks safety feels entitled to be on
a winning team this is the next level of
that yeah this is quarterbacks who feel
entitled because they have achieved a
high degree of success both regular
season and postseason but not as much as
they'd like they want more
so they either want an opportunity to
have influence in the effort to get more
where they are or
worst case scenario or possibly by what
tom brady has just achieved you go
somewhere else again
these are traits that when they manifest
themselves in a young child who must
always win
at everything he or she does it's
irritating it's grating it's off-putting
god you don't have to win everything
there jimmy come on you don't have to
don't cry it's just parcheesi we can
play another game right it's billy bob
thornton picking up the checkers and
slamming him against the wall and
thurman says want to play again you can
always play again but you got to win
everything right it's objectionable in a
little kid it's admirable in a grown man
always gotta win always gotta win always
gotta win always gotta win not winning
enough it's not good enough to get to
the playoffs sure we gotta now for jamal
adams it was because he never smelled
the playoffs russell wilson
one and done's not good enough i mean
that's where this is going and the
question is which quarterbacks are going
to try to flex their muscles in that
regard and as russell started to answer
that question he said well it depends on
who you are and it does you can't have
all 32 teams with quarterbacks
absolutely they're entitled to have a
spoon in the personnel stew but brady
clearly has earned it
the question is who else has earned it
nobody really owns it
right but it's not whether we think
they've earned it it's whether they
think they've earned it no i i know you
know i mean listen you said it we know
the ones that have earned it to a degree
already
but
i mean aaron rodgers has had no say up
there absolutely no say it on on
anything he told us he has he earned it
has he earned it yeah i mean he carries
a team every year he's the t he is the
team their their average is dishwater if
they don't have aaron rodgers and like
he said he said it at one point during
the year right like or maybe it was
early in the year like he vouched for
one guy in his life and they he ended up
in buffalo right remember that was the
one one reason and they cut him jake
that just tells you it's not a part of
the normal fabric of the nfl it's really
not this is very rare you know normal
may be changing well it might be there's
no doubt that's where i was going going
with this so this is going to take an
adjustment period for teams coaches gm's
you know and again i don't even think
tom brady was trying to do what he did
tom brady was just trying to get off and
go to another team that had talent and
then it's hey i got talent oh wait you
know rob gronkowski has been calling me
it wasn't like he called jason light and
then was like hey i want to have a say
in the team
you don't really think that just
happened spontaneously do you well i
mean it might have been part of the talk
but my point is that's a special
relationship i don't like i don't i'm
not he didn't go in there going i want
to help you run the team jason light and
bruce arians you know they knew what
they were getting they knew he was going
to coach and be the awesome leader he
was but the a b and antonio and antonio
brown and gronk thing you know they were
kind of in place before that so
that happened i just i what i'm saying
is organically and and i don't think he
was looking to have say in the team now
do they come to tom and go hey do you
have a preference on this right tackle
compared to this right tackle who we
keep on the roster sure maybe they do
same with the receivers but i think you
go past that you're dancing into
dangerous territory well yeah
a couple couple of things first
as it relates to what they did in the
draft
of all teams in the nfl the one with the
43 year old quarterback would have been
justified using a first round pick on a
quarterback they did not no they used
the first round pick on a tackle who
ended up being a very good contributor
and worfs yeah and that's got to be one
of those things that aaron rodgers would
look at and say but it would have been
nice if we'd used our first round pick
on somebody who would have helped me
right maybe it would have been the
difference between losing and winning
against the buccaneers in the nfc
championship antonio brown
the the other two teams
that that were mentioned yeah in
relation to brown were the packers in
the seahawks right now the packers
that went nowhere but
antonio brown and the seahawks had some
juice that had some legs and it did that
because who wanted him yeah russell
talked about wilson wanted him now the
ravens also were part of that too
because lamar jackson and hollywood
brown wanted him so they got dez bryant
instead dez bryant was the peace
offering when antonio brown wasn't
signed by the tampa but was signed by
the 10 bay buccaneers excuse me so
russell sees antonio brown
going to tampa bay that's the guy i
wanted maybe things would have been
different for us if we'd had antonio
brown with dk metcalf and tyler lockett
maybe that would have made it different
you know maybe i mean you can't prove
that it wouldn't have no and you see
what antonio brown helped do for the
tampa bay buccaneers it's hard it's hard
not to look at that and as it relates to
gronk that is a rare thing book and dk
metcalf not that he would drag him along
with him if he could force a trade i
don't think he's going to go to john
schneider or pete carroll and say well i
want dk metcalf as part of my trade
package but there are relationships
there that russell wilson has that you
could try to tap into at some point down
the road yeah no doubt about that and
and guys we'll definitely want to go
play for russell wilson there's no doubt
about that either you know but i i would
be one to sit here and argue
you know listen if they got an antonio
brown or anything like that that's an
offense there that they don't even they
wouldn't even know how to use all of it
they're not
part of the problem that's part of the
problem exactly that's why i wanted to
kind of just go there that's one of the
issues with the team too and why he's
frustrated right being hit too much we
talked about lack of creativity you know
if anybody ever listens to my podcast uh
this is something that hey pete dimoleta
little lightest can vouch for it you
know no ever easy just hey get the ball
throw to this guy type of throws for
russell wilson it's always drop back and
hey we got to wait for the guy to get
down field and make moves and anything
like that so um from that aspect there's
a lot of things they could do to help
support russell wilson the problem is
they
won a super bowl and went to back to
back super bowls and have a head coach
who
only knows really one style of football
he wants to play defense and run the
football and just have a few passes off
of that every now and then and that's
what he wants to do and
ultimately that's going to be
frustrating for most quarterbacks in
football right now in 2021
that's what d.k metcalf said not that
long ago that's what they do that's what
pete's always done on the ball a little
play action not a whole lot of
creativity not a lot of offensive genius
being brought to the table to diversify
things right create mismatches and allow
the offense to gain more yards and score
more points and you see all the crazy
stuff that these other teams do i mean
that move that the chiefs do now where
they bring a receiver
back in motion spinning and whirling all
around the place they do that almost
every play now it used to be something
you'd see once or twice a game i swear
we saw it at least 10 times in super
bowl 55 not that it worked nothing made
a difference no but it does really give
you that last second of uh oh
something's going on here
that that puts an extra little bit of
mental stress on a defense you don't you
never see that no from the seattle
seahawks
none of that mike none of it
so now
where does this go from here russell
wilson spoke favorably of shane waldron
the new offensive coordinator maybe he's
willing to give it a year to see if it
improves maybe this is just all part of
his effort more pointed than last year
to send messages to the organization
about what he would like to have happen
maybe this is their last chance i don't
know
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports